facebook apple amazon netflix and google
these five companies have a reputation
for paying some of the most exorbitant
salaries and offering the best perks in
the world at least tech workers
google for example has a median salary
of 295 000 per year while facebook comes
in at 292 000 per year and that's just
the median if you have any sort of
seniority within these companies they'll
be making closer to 500 000 per year if
not more
20 years ago these types of salaries
were only offered to c-suite executives
but these tech companies have made them
more common than ever
aside from these insane pay packages
many tech companies also have generous
work from home policies and unlimited
vacation time considering these
extraordinary perks working at these
companies is the top career goal for
many and getting a job at one of these
companies is extremely difficult at
google for instance the chances of
scoring a job for the average applicant
is just 0.2 percent hearing this you
would think that the people who make it
to the other side would be extremely
loyal and stick around for decades
but this is actually not the case
in fact these companies not only rank at
the top of the salary lists but also at
the top of the turnover lists
the average tenure of employees at these
companies is usually no more than two
years now it should be noted that this
study measures tenure and a non-turnover
so it is a bit skewed these companies
are always hiring new employees and
growing their workforces so naturally
the average tenure is going to skew
towards zero with that being said though
it's no secret that these companies have
high turnover if you know people within
these companies you know that most of
them jump around every few years and
this is the same case with most of their
co-workers as well
not to mention the thousands of youtube
videos and reddit posts about quitting
fame so why in the world do the best
places to work also have the highest
turnover
one of the top reasons many thank
engineers aren't enticed to stay at
their jobs is because the salary isn't
that big of a deal for them this isn't
to say that they're ungrateful for their
opportunities or that they don't care
about money when they enter the industry
they probably very much cared about the
high compensation and cool perks however
by the time they're 10 years into the
industry most of them simply achieve
financial freedom now they don't become
sent to millionaires or billionaires but
they almost always become
multi-millionaires if not decca
millionaires
but wait a minute even if you're getting
paid to 300 dollars per year
this only comes out to three million
dollars within 10 years
and by the time you deal with
california's taxes and living expenses
you'd be lucky to be left with a million
dollars so how did these guys manage to
save up over 5 million or 10 million
well the answer lies in stock
compensation every entry-level software
engineer at facebook earns 42 000 worth
of stock compensation every single year
you just have to get promoted once for
this number to nearly double to eighty
one thousand dollars per year and by the
time you get your second or third
promotion your stock compensation itself
is worth six figures if not multiple six
figures
also it's not like this money is being
invested into a 401k or the s p 500 this
money is literally being invested into
the fastest growing companies in the
world
over the past 10 years facebook grew 21x
amazon and group 21x apple group 13x
netflix crew 90x and google group 10x
now let's say you ended up at the
slowest grower which is google in 2012
and that you decide to stick around for
10 years
maybe you start at the lowest level
which is level three and make it to
level five this would mean that your
average stock compensation during this
time period would be eighty three
thousand dollars per year we can even
estimate conservatively and call it
seventy thousand dollars per year we can
also say that you're a financial idiot
and that you live paycheck to paycheck
you don't contribute to your 401k and
that you have no savings as long as you
don't sell your stock compensation you
would enjoy an annual growth rate of
27.8 percent and you'd be left with a
2.6 million dollars by the end of 10
years and that's the worst case scenario
if you were to do the same thing in
netflix which was the fastest growing of
the bunch you'd enjoy an annual growth
rate of 61
which would leave you with 13.3 million
dollars
if you jumped around every couple of
years like most of these guys do it you
probably would have ended somewhere in
between those two numbers likely five to
ten million dollars and that's just
stock compensation if you take advantage
of this company's 401k plans and invest
in the s p 500 yourself you can easily
boost a net worth of over 10 million
dollars by the time you're in your mid
30s when you're in such a position
earning more money gives you basically
zero tangible value people who are still
pursuing vault after this point are
simply playing the money game and seeing
how high they can get
but in terms of daily life earning more
money gives them no additional value and
they can retire at any time so it's no
wonder why paying salaries are not
enough to retain these employees
as you can see the vast majority of fang
employees become financially free at a
very young age so they're not driven to
stay at a company just for the salary
but even if they were driven by just the
salary it would still be in their best
interest and not stay at the same
company here's the thing when you stay
at the same company at best you'll earn
a three to five percent raise every year
if you switch companies strategically
however you can squeeze in a 10 to 20
raise every couple of years
and when you do this for a prolonged
period of time the person who constantly
switched jobs ends up earning a lot more
than the loyal employee according to
forbes employees who stay at companies
for longer than two years are paid 50
less on average now this isn't to say
that you should switch companies every
24 months because that'll likely become
a red flag very quickly
but it is in your best interest to
switch periodically as in every five to
seven years and this is especially true
in the fang world while it's extremely
difficult to get into fang once you're
in and have a couple of years under your
build it's comically easy to switch
between these companies here's the thing
the reason acceptance rates at fan
companies are so low is not because
these companies don't need more talent
these companies are always desperate for
more talent and the reason acceptance
rates are so low is because it's
extremely difficult to find employees
that are on the caliber that they're
looking for but if you've already passed
the screening process of one of their
competitors they can be pretty confident
that you'll be a good hire
fan companies are infamous for
approaching employees from competitors
in fact they're almost always embroiled
in a bunch of lawsuits regarding
stealing employees and intellectual
property and things along those lines so
as top tier thank talent you can use
this rivalry amongst these companies to
maximize your own compensation something
else to note is that switching to other
fan companies is not their only option
in many cases they go on to found their
own companies and given that these guys
have intelligence experience and
networks the odds are very much stacked
in their favor this is why companies
like xiaomi pinterest ship technologies
upstart and youtube were all founded by
x silicon valley employees imagine if
eric yuan stayed at cisco instead of
founding zoom or if reed hoffman stayed
at paypal instead of founding linkedin
more times than not these guys have
their eyes on targets that are much
larger than just 10 to 15 million
dollars often times that they're looking
for hundreds of millions if not billions
so they're not gonna stick around at
google just so they can get a few
hundred thousand dollars and free food
and given that fang recruits the
absolute best talent in the world it's
not surprising that many of their
employees have such ambitions for most
of them it's just a matter of time until
they outgrow their roles and fame
while larger goals and financial freedom
often play a factor in fang employees
jumping ship these are not the only
reasons
often times it just comes down to
employees burning out and either wanting
to take it slow or get a fresh start we
commonly hear about how great it is to
work at these companies but a lot of
that is simply because that's how these
companies want us to perceive them all
of these companies are master marketers
when it comes to selling their products
and it's no different when it comes to
recruiting they want us to think that
their jobs are the absolute best when in
reality their jobs are actually super
stressful but wait a minute don't fan
companies have extremely generous
vacation policies and paid time off and
things like that well yes they do but
here's the cool thing for them these
companies don't have to be the bad guys
to cultivate an extremely competitive
and stressful working environment they
don't need to implement cutthroat
managers and directors or hang scary
deadlines over your head when you place
thousands of the smartest and the most
competitive individuals together it's
only natural that they're gonna try to
outdo each other you don't need to scare
them or threaten them to work hard and
not take vacations these guys are
naturally not going to take vacations
because they want to shine they want
that next promotion and they want that
higher status and they want to boost
their egos they all have their own
selfish reasons for working hard and
they're all highly motivated which works
out perfectly for these companies the
companies can be the good guys offering
great salaries and awesome perks while
the employees end up working 60 hours
per week or more by themselves many of
these guys thrive under these working
conditions and they end up as a vp at a
fan company or a c-suite executive at a
startup but many also burn themselves
out and end up scaling back or switching
companies this is why most employees at
apple report struggling with burnout and
why almost half of apple and amazon
employees don't have a close friend at
work this is also why only about half of
employees at most fan companies are
actually happy at their jobs the only
exception to this rule is netflix and
the reason they have such happy
employees is because they lean into a
contractor model that turns over
employees even faster so most of their
employees never even get past the
honeymoon phase personally i've seen
this play out in real life in high
school i had a computer science teacher
from fang and a coach that was from the
nfl while both of these guys were from
completely different industries i think
their reasoning for taking such a
massive pay cut were identical they were
simply burnt out from always having to
perform at their peak ability now i
should also mention that the computer
science teacher has since returned to
fang so clearly these guys can never
truly suppress their inner urge to
constantly progress in their careers
but at the same time they're never truly
satisfied at any one of these jobs
they're constantly in this limbo state
where they're hopping jobs every few
years perpetually trying to find inner
peace
in the end while fan companies love
trying to convince us that they're the
best places to work it's simply not true
job satisfaction is usually not derived
from high salaries or fancy perks
virtually all the jobs with the highest
satisfaction have something to do with
helping others whether that be providing
educational services or therapy and at
feng all you're usually doing is making
the biggest companies in the world even
bigger there's also the whole ethical
and moral dilemma as well
google and facebook are notorious for
privacy concerns now none of this is to
say that you shouldn't pursue a job at
feng feng is an outstanding place to
build your career and achieve financial
freedom but what feng isn't is a place
to achieve a long-term zen and that's
why turnover at feng is so high would
you leave a job at feng comment that
down below
also drop a like if you wish you had a
fake salary and of course consider
checking out our discord community to
suggest future video ideas and consider
subscribing see more questions logically
answered but until then i'm hari and
i'll see you guys on the next one
you